today's video we're going to be covering
the uh
video that preach suggested we watch so
all right here we go
do you guys remember our friend miguel
the guy with the horrible rejection
story
and then and then she dropped it she
goes
you have got to be the ugliest guy
in the no dude you i know you probably
don't believe me no way she responded
yeah
who responds like that well after
further examination
i found out that my man has had zero
zero sexy sex did he call it sexy sex
you said sexy sex yo y'all imagine y'all
y'all going to sex therapist you're like
man i'm a fortune i'm i can't get laid
wonderful glad you could sign up
jonathan
here at prime reela we're gonna help you
get some sexy sex
[ __ ] if you don't take your money back
and walk out that door immediately
all right let's let's just listen to
this guy do his best impersonation of
tony robbins
[Laughter]
so who better to help him out than the
virgin converter himself
i did it two years ago with the 21 year
old i'm gonna do it again with this 35
year old but this time
we need to see where he's at so we
brought seven girls
to speed date our friend miguel let's
hop in today
hi nice to meet you nice to meet you my
name is eagle what's your name miguel
yeah miguel bear nice to meet you uh
i have to do this because my mom said it
was essential
i have to have gum so my breath smells
like kind of nice
okay so are you close with your mom i'm
very close with my mom she's kind of
like my best friend right now
no no no
i refuse to believe that a virgin goes
off like that i gotta
take um my mom's told me that i have to
put gum he would put gum beef he would
take gum before
but then people were like what about
skippy skippy's a different breed
skippy has like evidence of authenticity
i don't know something about this just
seems fake
but that's just b has evidence of uh yes
yeah i tend to yes i don't watch a
skipping video and think oh my god this
is
fake but that's just me personally it's
staged no that's not what i think at all
when i watch a skippy video
so family is very important to you uh
yeah just my mom right now my dad's not
really in the picture okay
do you watch video do you like video
games i play some video games i haven't
in a while
no one's okay very nervous
you can tell you look a little nervous
but that's okay but do you like video
games
um i used to play a lot more but lately
i haven't played yeah yeah do you like
video games do you like video games i'm
feeling really nervous well
it's okay to be video games yeah do you
like video games do you like video games
do you like video games do you like
video games do you like video
i feel like there's a producer in his
ear being like ask her if she likes
video games again
ask her again ask her again we didn't
get a clear answer
ask again roger that but i do watch
naruto
okay so i watch some anime but i haven't
played too many video games lately i
love anime
yeah what's your favorite anime dragon
ball z i'm saying you love
you know you rock with anime because you
watching our toys like saying you love
food because you eat mcdonald's
you know he's like yeah but not really
you know what i mean but if you're like
i know
i don't know what go ahead if someone
everyone everybody
that told me that they were a fan of
anime
and you asked them what do you watch and
they go to dragon ball z
is not a fan of anime
yeah do you look really pretty
thank you wow oh my god
oh are you pretty good what's your name
my name is miguel what is it nice to
meet you my name's ashley ashley
wow you have a really pretty name and
you're really pretty too thank you
[Laughter]
do you like video games i love video
games i don't really play video games
you don't play video games
there's this character in my game that
i'm playing right now civilization
okay that looks just like you and it
just reminded me of it and i thought to
myself like oh my god
maybe she is the queen of this country i
don't know
this is so funny do you do you mind if i
give you like a hug just like a hug
goodbye
um
i will say something like it this thing
is so disconjointed is random
yes you look like this girl from my
video game awesome yeah
i don't know go ahead do it do it do it
do it everybody want to hear the yuck
could i get a hug
hey producer was that good enough all
right
your your
what about you i'm the aztecs you want
to be canada cause i'll conquer you
all right
that was hard to watch my stomach is
churning right now
i don't know how hard it was for you to
sit through that you know the only thing
that's making me more uncomfortable than
this guy
is is this dude over here who who just
seems like he's coming in
well right back at you with uh to 93.5
radio folks and that's my stomach is
churning
how are you guys feeling at home right
now welcome to vice city
everything feels weird about this it was
okay at first you know like he was
respectful
nice complimented me sweet um
i wouldn't go out with him again though
yo at which point in your life would you
think to yourself
the most authentic part of these dating
videos is the ig models
to save rep to say do you know how
fake and inauthentic you have to be to
to make me forget that these are ig
models
i thought it was nice that he asked
before he hugged me and approached me
but also he smelled so
bad just like cheap cologne not fresh
say no more yeah we'll go fix this guy
up my man
what's going on here i you know there's
so many pretty girls
look i saw your advance on the last girl
i respect how respectful you were she
said something interesting
what are you wearing i'm just curious uh
ripped abs
by bud no no you're not i really am
what are you wearing and the man goes
straight to cologne
is that normal wouldn't you think he's
talking about clothes
yeah someone said yo [ __ ] what are you
wearing i'd be looking on my fit
straight up that's why i'm saying this
whole thing seems very
[ __ ] look at the screen check out our
line of fragrances this is a commercial
this is an informational
it's it's i found it at the corner he
wants to be nice
he found it at the corner store i don't
know who this guy's name is
okay uh teaching listen if you're gonna
fake this stuff at least make it more
authentic
get some better actors have somebody
write your dialogue
because this is so clearly set up it's
cringy and i think the one thing i take
issue with
is how people go out of their way to
paint these
virgins as like always the most awkward
and the worst of the worst
and he played heavily into that
stereotype to make this fake commercial
and to then sell them a product so my
assumption
is he's gonna bring out this thing spray
it on the man
and he's going to get some success
afterwards
[Music]
this is going to be the start of our
transformation today this right here is
santa lucia
it's a parfum made in france it is my
own so i'm a little bit biased but
we curate it for one reason alone when
you're on dates
yeah you smell like a man you smell like
a man that's magnetic come
closer spray it on ryan no you can't
spray it on
no no no no no no no no no no no
no you can't spread on you cannot spray
i know i got cologne you cannot spray
new perfume on old fragrances you didn't
wash your body's gonna ask
it's gonna no you kid that's a no-no
hold up explain no no well the thing
that happened is that even then okay
when you spray a cologne and you're not
even supposed to spray it here
you know oftentimes whenever you spray a
cologne they tell you to spray here and
everything and stuff
you can't do that you actually cannot do
that whenever you try
in the store that's why in the stores
that actually know what they're talking
about in colognes
they spray on a piece of paper a piece
of fabric
and you spray it in the air then you
have the neutral cologne
then that cologne okay that you're gonna
spray on you after you wash
and you don't put heavy uh heavy scented
um uh soap after you wash and you put
that cologne
that cologne is gonna interact with your
sweat
that's why every cologne is not for
everybody sometimes the ph
of your skin and of your uh your sweat
and the bacteria that's on your side are
gonna interact and are gonna turn the
cologne sometimes some people
we could be two guys wearing the same
cologne
um me is gonna work on you it's not
gonna work
okay so because we don't have the same
ph
now you cannot spring you you already
have something on it it smells bad
you're adding on top of that is just
gonna turn even if you have a great
cologne
it already doesn't feel up about good
it's gonna be tainted it's not good
that's a big big huge perfume no no
well you guys heard it here first if you
cheat teaching man fashion that's the
first thing you should tell them
you should tell the dude go take a
shower all right go take a shot because
you have that other cologne on you
it's gonna turn other thing i can't just
be like yeah
here's your cologne that thing is good
for you or anybody that's not how
cologne works
everybody got a different kind of
cologne my [ __ ] is my
i got i got a couple of like i i wear
skirty if you will
a couple of brands of him and our i wear
a burberry touch that's
my that's my scent right that's what i
wear
but those perfume i cannot go to anybody
and be like
where it is no because there's going to
be some spices there's going to be some
wood
that would pause there's going to be
leather uh smelled in there there's
going to be bergamot there's going to be
different kind of smells they're going
to interact with who you are and going
to interact with your musk you can't
just
propose a must to someone it doesn't
work like that none of this is real
next time a chick asks you what are you
wearing next time she asks you what are
you wearing you know what you're going
to say
yeah come closer that's what you're
going to say man
i don't think you got it did you get the
pun you didn't get the pun i'm trying to
help you out here see i'm
i'm making you smell good and i'm giving
you the one-liner i'm i'm gonna say that
okay i got seven more girls coming all
right okay
hi um uh come closer
[Music]
do you smell it yeah do you like it yeah
yeah it's uh listen my man thought he
was neo just over there come closer
normally you want to do that a little
bit later hey hey hey
hey hey hey come closer you like that
smell yeah
yeah you like that you like that my old
one wasn't good but this new one's good
huh yeah you like
um uh come closer
jeez do you smell it do you like it
yeah yeah yeah my dad's not really like
in the picture
but yeah we she's like my best friend um
it's a good time
yeah are you close to your mom yeah
you're really close yeah
is she like your best friend too or i
wouldn't say my best friend
yeah but we're really close yeah welcome
good how are you
nice to meet you nice to meet you um do
you like uh do you like cologne
cologne yeah uh i'm big into sense yeah
yeah
all right uh come closer
it smells good my mom said it's puerto
rican and my dad's side's dominican word
word where do you like video games
i'm close to my mom my mom's my best
friend how's your
my dad's not in the picture but
i got this cologne that my friend gave
me do you like anime i like dragon ball
actually my mom's part mexican too oh
really but i don't really know that much
about that side of my family yeah yeah
are you close to your mom yeah yeah it's
like you would just say she's like your
best friend
i
i don't like i feel like this is what i
feel like the moment he hears anything
about a mom he's like
time to insert my question are you close
to your mom i mean
i mean an alien invasion could be
happening and soldiers could be like
quick
we have to get away from the mothership
and he can be like are you close to your
boss
we're close to the mother [ __ ] oh is she
your best friend
is your mothership the best friend my
name is miguel i'm mexican i'm part
mexican
oh but i don't really know that is it
because of
because is it because it's your dad's
part that is not in the picture
because my dad is not the picture yeah
for sure yeah seems really nice i like
her
because she says that uh her mom is her
best friend yeah my mom is
my best friend oh that's great yeah yeah
we had handle the timeout
that is not what i told you to do with
that line i but i told them to come
closer
we got a lot of work to do i i see the
problem do you see the problem do you
feel the problem or no
i i think i'm talking about all the
things that i like i don't see any
problems
okay we're gonna fix you up i'm gonna
fix you up
all right this man he's gonna be a
different man in three episodes
okay i like the challenge yeah for sure
yes i'm in
don't forget to get the cologne santa
lucia
the cologne that you wear when you like
dragon ball z and your mom is your best
friend
come close smell santalucia
yeah i don't think i can do this people
are asking if this is scripted
so what do you think i think it is
that's not what i said look at this
scripted
it's not how perfume works at all ah
[ __ ] i just realized i'm a nerd perfume
you know what my favorite perfume is hmm
perfume called dragon ball z
hey man listen to me this looks super
scripted and there's a lot of guys who
do stuff like this they
fake approaches they fake pickup artist
stuff they fake it there's guys who do
it for real
but there's other ones who are fake and
uh this one this one screams fake
screams hey but million uh 5 million
subscribers man
this is my opinion maybe you guys
disagree but uh yeah looks extremely
scripted
so those are my thoughts same if you are
uh you're one of the people who were
involved in this and you know it's fake
feel free to contact us
but anyways that's it for me i hope you
guys don't fall for stuff like this
here you're struggling with ladies that
[Music]
much
ah
[Music]
oh